Magic: the Gathering is a card game
where cards are drawn from a deck,
and this naturally introduces a certain amount of
randomness—sometimes draws are good, other times
they’re less good. I imagine this isn’t news to
you if you play this game a lot, either that or
you’ve had a luck streak worthy of legend. In the
worst case, you’ve got the dead card—a card that
you draw and it doesn’t do anything meaningful
whatsoever. To some extent this sort of draw
is just a fact of life, and it’s not something
you’re going to be able to fully avoid. Drawing
a land when you don’t want one or not drawing
a land when you do will always be a struggle,
and though MDFCs, utility lands, and other tools
can mitigate some of this unfortunate variance,
it will always be somewhat present. But what about
among nonland cards? Well, the number of nonland
draws that end up being more or less dead can
vary immensely deck to deck, and this number will
often result from the specific choices that went
into the deckbuilding process. So, in this video,
I’m going to go through the sorts of cards
that often end up being dead draws in a deck,
and how to make your deck play more smoothly
without harming the things you enjoy about it.
To start with, let’s talk about an example of a
deck with more or less no dead nonland cards—a
deck with 35 Swamps, and 64 Rat Colonies. All
of this deck’s nonland cards synergize with
each other, and you’ll generally never draw a
card and have it be entirely useless. However,
this obviously comes at a cost. An exclusively
Rat Colony and Swamp deck has an exceptionally
specific gameplan with little to no
flexibility—either a board with a
moderate number of high power, low toughness
creatures wins you the game, or it doesn’t.
I choose this example not as a point of
aspiration, but rather as an indication
of what reduces dead draws—these Rat Colonies
have no variation in the tasks they perform,
all creatures that can beat down opponents, and
they also all synergize with each other. So,
the start of dead draw mitigation starts by paying
attention to these two things—what does a card
accomplish, and what else does it synergize
with. Let’s start by discussing the latter.
EDH as a format strongly encourages synergy,
and by synergy I simply mean cards doing more
together than they’d do on their own. This is the
case because the format is 40 life instead of 20,
and has three opponents instead of one, conditions
that necessitate that gameplay be volumetrically
larger. You simply gotta have more stuff going
on. Obviously the most simple version of this
is the Rat Colony example—your deck is made up
of a creature that will have more power the more
copies of it are in play, but this isn’t enough
volume for a lot of EDH games. So let’s take the
example of a somewhat larger lad—Kylar, Sigardian
Emissary. Kyler is a 5 mana 2/2 that gets a +1/+1
counter whenever another human enters and
gives your other humans +1/+1 for each of
those counters. So, this is a commander who can
dramatically power up a board of humans if left
unchecked, but whose high mana cost and small
starting statline make him a bit of a removal
magnet. Naturally, the primary synergy package
here is humans, but different cards here will have
different profiles of the situations in which
they’re good. Coppercoat Vanguard is good as
long as you have other humans—pretty decent
assumption for a human deck—and also gives
the commander a bit of extra protection. This
card should rarely feel useless, and could even
be a pretty solid anthem if there are tokens
out. That brings me to another card—Increasing
Devotion is a large-scale token creator, and
this one is slightly more complicated. It’s
fantastic if you currently have Kyler on the
board plus some other humans to swing with,
decent if you have some other human ETB effects
on board like Lossarnach Captain or Champion of
the Parish in play, also decent if you have an
anthem at the ready to pump them up in size,
and pretty mediocre if you have none of these
support cards. The flashback prevents it from ever
feeling truly horrible, but it might be a passable
play at best if you have neither the commander
available nor any of 15 cards in the deck that
can amplify this card up to being a decent play.
Most of the popular synergy cards for a Kyler
deck will do things with humans, and with some
exceptions, most of these will be pretty okay.
However, synergy can go a bit deeper—you can
venture into the magical world of subthemes.
Take +1/+1 counters—the commander uses them,
and the average Kyler deck has around 12
cards in the 99 that feature +1/+1 counters,
so some players choose to add Metastatic Evangel,
a card that proliferates whenever another nontoken
creature enters under your control. Paired with
the commander, this card can turn powerful plays
into utterly earth-shattering plays, but it
also doesn’t do much to smooth over Kyler’s
weaknesses. If he gets removed, the counters
go with him. Put into the average Kyler deck
this card benefits 12 other cards, which isn’t
nothing but also isn’t great—paired with its
somewhat ephemeral support of the commander, I’d
skip this card personally. Now, does this mean our
Phyrexian Cleric friend belongs in no decks? Not
necessarily—some players might be running larger
numbers of +1/+1 counter cards than the average
player does, and others might be building the
deck in a way that’s likely to keep Kyler around
more of the time. This card might even be a star
player in some decks—it’s certainly not a bad
card. But, these are the sorts of considerations
you should be making when you’re deciding
whether or not to add a synergy piece. How
often will it be in a situation to support other
cards, and how substantial will that support be?
When I’m building decks, I’ll typically keep track
of support for different themes and subthemes them
via Archidekt’s category system. I’ll have
the baseline categories I put cards into,
but also secondary categories for things like
flicker, ETB, graveyard enabler, graveyard payoff,
and so on. When I’m adding cards and trying to
flesh out a list I’ll be mostly viewing the deck
on the primary categories tab to keep things
visually neat, but as I start to prune and
sculpt the list I’ll start bouncing back and forth
between that and the multi-category tab, and see
if the various parts of my deck have the right
amount of support. This multi-category approach
is also nice for evaluating individual cards
because I can immediately see and be reminded
of all the reasons I included a particular card,
which also indirectly tells me the situations in
which the card will or won’t be useful. As an
example, let’s take a card in a subtheme-heavy
Phyrexian deck I recently built—Vat of Rebirth.
The categories here tell me that it’s a source
of value that’s payoff for having things in the
graveyard—so as a baseline I can check how much
stuff I have that helps get things into the
graveyard, with a focus on creatures since
that’s what this can reanimate. However, the
other categories also tell me things about this
card—this card will be stronger alongside
counter-amplifiers like proliferate cards,
and it’ll also be stronger when I have untap
effects on the field. It’s also an artifact,
and a low-cost one at that, so it’ll synergize
with several other cards for that reason alone,
and those cards are helpfully already organized
into a category for me to check on. I can think
about all the other combinations of cards this
card may or may not be on the field with, and
based on that I can approximate roughly how often
this card will be dead. The answer for this card
is that it’ll be dead some modest percentage of
the time in the early game, maybe 25% of the time,
but there are also situations in which it’ll be
very powerful due to other supporting pieces being
around, so I’ve currently deemed it worth staying
in. I also love the art and flavor of the card,
which does end up being a non-negligible
factor for a lower-power deck like this.
So that’s synergies, but that’s only one part
of what makes a card dead or not dead. Another
big factor to keep in mind is what stage
of a game a card is useful in, and before
I get into that I briefly want to introduce a
concept—Quadrant Theory. This sounds complicated,
but it’s basically just a way of analyzing
different situations in which a card could
be played. A basic example goes something like
this—we have this four-quadrant box, and in this
case we’ll choose to label the top side based on
the size of an opponent’s board and the left side
based on the size of my board. Now, let’s consider
the card Teleportal—how is this in different
situations? Well, if we both have small boards,
this card sucks! Not many creatures to affect,
and not many creatures to get past. If I have a
small board and my opponent has a large board,
well this is still pretty bad but maybe there
are some niche scenarios where it lets me get
in for the last couple points of damage after my
opponent has stabilized against my aggression,
and it can be cast single-target for
two mana in a pinch. If I have a large
board and my opponent has a small board,
well the unblockable isn’t doing much,
but at least I’m getting a power buff
on all my creatures. Where this card is
a straight up banger is when we both have
large boards—this is the sort of situation
where I’m probably praying for this card as
a topdeck, since it’s getting maximum effect.
This concept was originally designed with limited
formats in mind, where cards are typically simpler
and players tend to be on the lookout for narrow
slivers of advantage. Fundamentally, though,
Quadrant Theory has a straightforward
and universally applicable purpose:
it exists to make sure that you’re thinking
about all the situations a card might exist in,
not just the ideal ones. A variant of this might
be to analyze a card based on the stage of the
game we’re in. Take a card in a mid-power deck—how
is that card in the early game? How does it fare
in the mid-game? Now, decks will typically gain
more card advantage over the course of the game,
so it’s fine to weight your analyses a bit more
heavily toward the later parts of the game as
long as you have the support to get there, but
you should still consider different versions
of that late game. There will be the version
of the later game where you’re hitting your
stride without setbacks, but what happens
if a board wipe was played? Or how about
if you have your board but your life total has
been taxed heavily by a more aggressive deck?
How about if a midrange opponent is pulling
far ahead and you need to either kill some key
permanents or heavily diminish their life total?
Different games will demand different things,
and you should figure out how your different
cards play in those different games.
For a simple example, let’s
talk about my Radha deck,
a deck designed to be as resilient and
consistent with its gameplay as possible.
It typically curves mana dork commander
into 4 mana ramp spell into 6 and 7 drops,
with the goal of continuing to ramp and eventually
getting to 20 or more lands. With that in mind,
let’s talk about a couple cards that are present
here. Drakuseth, Maw of Flames is a 7 mana 7/7
flier that deals 4 damage to one target and three
damage to two targets when it attacks. Oddly,
this is a card that I’m actually most excited to
see early, as landing it on turn 4 can be a pretty
back-breaking opener if it doesn’t get removed due
to its sheer power as a removal engine. However,
it’s still plenty solid as a topdeck later in
the game, what with its good flying statline and
attack ability that remains respectable even if
the creature size game has been heating up a bit.
This sort of card is a good symbol of what this
deck is best at—it’s just always decent. For an
example with a decidedly different power profile,
let’s consider a different card—Captivating Crew.
Now, this card is pretty bad in the early game—4
mana to threaten an opposing creature is just
never what I want to do with my mana in the first
six turns of the game, and I’m rarely all that
happy when my turn 4 or 5 cascade card pops out
this treason-triggering-troupe rather than a ramp
spell. However, what keeps me from cutting the
card is its sheer versatility in the late game—as
long as I have enough lands, it almost
always feels good. If I’m ahead on board,
I can pull the last two or three blockers out
from under an opponent and smack them down
before they have the chance to stall things out.
If I’m behind on board, it often means I had a
more-aggressive-but-worse-scaling rollout in the
early game, in which case I can often leverage
opposing life totals to get some favorable chump
blocks, or at least utilize some abilities on
opposing creatures. If the board is in a state
of parity, it’s the best of both worlds—I
can nab my opponent’s best threats and turn
a 5-attacker 5-blocker standstill into an 8-2
or 9-1 smackdown. I was a bit hesitant to add
this card to the deck initially, but the sheer
consistency with which it feels great in the late
game has made it one of my favorite topdecks.
So, so far the lesson of this video has been
more or less “be very careful with cards whose
use-cases are highly specific.” But I can
already hear some of you saying “but Alex,
I want to play those cards. You’re describing
a lot of my favorite cards, are you telling me
I need to cut those?” And the secret third part
of this video is that you can play those cards,
and you can do it fully responsibly, *but* doing
so requires one specific thing—card selection.
This may be achieved by playing lots of filtering,
or by playing a generally high-velocity deck,
but the basic principle is simple—dead cards
won’t matter as much if you simply see more
cards. A basic example of this might be an ongoing
source of filtering like Merfolk Looter—it’s
not card advantage, but it doubles the number
of new cards you see each turn, and lets you
rid yourself of any that aren’t immediately
useful. Same deal if you play lots of scry,
or lots of selective draw. Don’t like the card
on top? Ditch it. Don’t want a card in the top
4? Great, pick a different one. This even
goes for actual factual card advantage—if
your deck is consistently able to set up
multiple extra cards per turn in advantage,
that’s often going to outpace your ability to
cast what you draw, and as long as you have
more useful stuff to play instead there’s
really no harm in drawing that situational
card. This was a major fact of life back when
I played a mono black deck in my youth—I’d find
one of my massive sources of draw, and then
suddenly I could effortlessly cut through
the quagmire of redundant pieces and specific
answers that made up the top of my library.
At the end of the day, all I’m trying to do
is make you aware of the forces at play here.
If your deck feels sluggish or awkward or swingy,
there’s a good chance dead cards are playing a
major contributing role in that feeling. If you
frequently find yourself unable to meaningfully
contribute to a game for stretches of time,
it might be time to audit the contents of your
deck. There are so many cards that look great and
ingrain themselves in our brains as simply a part
of our deck, basically getting to skip any sort
of auditioning process for simple vibes reasons.
I ran Don’t Blink in my Sharuum Slide deck
for several months because the elevator pitch
for it sounds great—it’s a card with cycling
that can also be a big source of removal if
I have Astral Slide out, turning those exiles
into somewhat more lasting removal. However,
when I actually examined what this card is
accomplishing, it doesn’t fit the desired
profile of a removal spell with cycling at
all. I can cycle it, which is cool when I
have some sort of cycling engine already up
and going, and I can also cast it normally,
which is cool when I have an even bigger sort
of cycling engine already up and going. Missing
entirely is the part of this card that has any
impact on the game when Astral Slide isn’t in
play outside of wasting two mana, and as a result
it got cut for the far superior card Spectacular
Pileup when Aetherdrift came out. For a simple
exercise, think about the cards in your deck,
and try to notice—is there a card where you
seem to be thinking something along the lines
of “this card hasn’t had any great games yet,
but it’s awesome in theory.” If that’s the case,
you’re gonna wanna check your theories a
bit and take a longer look at that card.
Thanks for watching, and thanks to my
Patrons for supporting the channel,
some of whom are on screen now. I’m actually
gearing up for a cool patron video soon,
which will go something as follows—I’ll take
card suggestions from patrons, and then I’ll
be running a poll with a bunch of those cards
to determine three of those cards that I’ll
need to construct a deck around. Then,
I’ll build the deck, and put a video out
on my patreon that details what the deck
does and the process of constructing it.
If you want to be a part of the input for that,
you can sign up for my Patreon for $3 a month.